[MUSIC]
In recent times, there have been massive
investments by companies and
firms in internal databases and this has
provided us the means to
provide an unprecedented look at the
behavior of employees.
The interaction of those employees with
the firm's customers and
a new way to think about and quantify
employee productivity.
So my research is about taking these very
large,
big data sets on the internal organization
of firms.
To better understand employee
productivity,
to better understand the design of
intensive systems and
to better understand how these two aspects
can be brought together to
improve the interaction of a company with
its customers.
[MUSIC]
There are two kinds of data that we're
talking about here.
One is on the internal behavior of firms.
Off the type routinely collected by Human
Resources Management Systems or
off the type collected routinely by ERP
Systems or
Enterprise Resource Planning Software,
which collects data on what your employees
are doing.
How they're spending time on their
activities?
And combining this with compensation data.
For example, the salaries, quotas,
commissions.
Putting these two aspects together, we can
ask, which salaries work?
Which quotas work?
Which bonuses work for which sales agent?
And asked the more broader question,
should we have bonuses at all?
Do quotas work well?
[MUSIC]
Quotas and bonuses and commissions have
very good incentive properties,
because they give you a lot of incentives
to put in a lot of effort.
Because they form a goal that you have to
work towards in order to earn commissions.
While that is true, the flip side is many
people understand that quotas and things
like these also have some bad properties
related to gaming or timing issues.
If sales people are gaming the quota in
this manner,
it can actually create some really bad
behavior and distortions.
In the past in theory, it was thought that
these distortions are interesting,
but intellectually a curiosum.
Maybe not that important in the real
world.
Some of the insights that we have been
able to generate using real data from
real companies is that the magnitudes of
these distortions can be so huge.
That the positive effects of quotas and
bonuses may well be overwhelmed if they're
not designed correctly, because these
distortions just have a huge magnitude.
[MUSIC]
Different people are different.
There is lot of heterogeneity among
salespeople, amongst your employees.
And it's not likely to be the case that
there is a one size fit,
fits all approach.
The value of the data is that we can
actually measure heterogeneity in
employees employee's skill.
And we can look at the data and
say that this employee in this particular
territory.
For every time he called on a particular
doctor,
his conversion of a call into sales volume
is very high.
While some other employee when he called
on a doctor for
a same number of calls, his conversion or
production of sales is very low.
So we have the ability to use the data to
fine tune contracts to
the individual employee level.
For example, certain kinds of employees
who are quote unquote,
high powered might prefer that most of
their compensation is
coming from commissions as opposed to
straight salary.
So if you hi,
hire the right kind of employees, you
could make a commission-based system work
much better than if you have employees who
prefer straight salary.
On the other hand, if you are forced
because of institutional or
within company considerations that you can
have only a particular kind of
incentive scheme, you might think, well, I
need to have the right kind of
employees in order to make this incentive
scheme work.
What I'm trying to say here is that the
hiring and firing of employees,
as well as the design of the incentives to
incent them have to go hand and hand.
[MUSIC]